[Music]
okay
do you guys know anyone who's doing like
online schooling right now like
like distance learning all of my nephews
yes
yes have you spoken to them about it uh
a little bit
yeah i've spoke to my sister because she
takes care of them and she says it's
kind of difficult because everyone's
attention
span sucks and i think the class is also
not the full length either it's not like
the whole
half day it's like an hour or two or
something right
yeah school is like short last or like
an hour no no day yeah for the for
well i think for the whole day it's like
a couple hours or something
oh my niece does five hours of classes
she's like five
years old oh
she's bored as [ __ ] damn are they like
teaching teaching are they like doing
sing-alongs and stuff because she's five
it's both yeah it's pretty rudimentary
[ __ ] like abc's and stuff and it's just
a video call yeah five hours is a lot
with some breaks but yeah yeah isaac's
only on zoom for four hours i think
no it's like two because by 12 he's
already done he's he starts like at 10
no no he starts like sorry never mind he
starts at eight
yeah yeah you're right about four hours
yeah she's in san diego i don't know if
that's
different and different school district
well it is being reported
uh that a lot of parents particularly in
florida
have been spotted smoking weed
drinking walking around half naked it's
so good
in the background of these kids online
classes
to the point where now there's teachers
being like come on people like do you
not realize that we are recording
it's so funny because it says parents
please make sure that you have on proper
clothing when you're walking behind your
child's computer because we've seen
them in their drawers their bras and
everything else so there was a video of
this uh this mom so this
daughter was in the video like this and
she's walking by like lighting uh
lighting a joint yeah and she goes [ __ ]
it's hilarious at least
i like when they're drinking in a clear
cup and it's like how do they know i'm
drinking sangria
and it's like it's all right there's red
you got something around in there
i know and then they were saying they
were mentioning that uh this one teacher
said i had a father
no shirt drinking a beer at 11 45 in the
morning
and then another one what day was it
though let's give him a chance
what day would be appropriate a sunday a
sunday that's correct there's no school
on sunday
awesome no school on sunday unless it's
sunday school
does that make it better or weirder
what y'all learning about jesus christ
hey that's a good guy right there to
jesus to jesus
yeah jesus christ opened a cold one for
jesus
drinking his blood right now
but yeah another one another teacher
said i did have a parent who sat on the
couch and we could see an
ankle monitor on her leg oh [ __ ]
that's my beeper that's where i keep it
but damn that's old
but dude like i mean parents are
apparently not apparently
not actually noticing that their kid is
on
online right now like talking to their
teacher i mean these don't sound like
very attentive parents anyway
these poor kids it sucks that that's
their household
and it it's kind of i guess a good thing
that then the teachers can see the type
of environment these kids are not
if that's an excuse we should blame the
teachers if the kids aren't learning we
need to blame
the teachers i've always said this and i
will say it again
you blame the teachers that's it
change will happen that's right
[Laughter]
[Music]
but yeah so other teachers are saying
that they fear that other students would
be exposed to a
hard to process level of street smarts
by getting glimpses into
the hard parting homes yeah that's an
interesting way to phrase it
almost sounds positive yeah oh my god
afraid there's going to be too much
street smarts in the zoomies
just be too cool i just love mom coming
in the room being like
shots shot like honey could you pour it
for me like come on baby
let's go she's like it's bad luck if i
pour if i pour the sake myself you're
gonna pour it
you guys know that custom that's that's
big yes so they're multicultural and
classy
educational i know what we're learning
something i know it's a respect thing
soju you have uh someone else for you
that's correct wait what
so if i want to drink it i have to ask
someone else to oh i don't know if you
ask someone else
normally someone else is like we'll pull
it for you exactly out of respect i
think
i don't know i'm not korean wait tell me
teach me because you know so
i don't know yes white man please teach
me yes yeah teach us
he brought it up i know it's just funny
two whites plain
so okay we took over a bunch of this
area too so don't even come at me
we made the rules uh no so so
apparently uh this is just something
i've done with nikki since
our first date which was sushi and i had
never gone to sushi before but
um she's like hey we you poor for me and
i pour for you and that's just what we
do since
oh that's cute that's cute thing wait so
but then like what is the actual like
traditional i have no [ __ ] it's a
korean tradition and this is explained
to me by my friend if you're younger you
pour it right yeah if you eat the
younger one you pour
for the older person and then and then
it's something about
always turning to the left as well or
something like that you drink to the
side so that's
okay you're being polite yeah oh so
there's definitely a culture there conan
and ryan went to japan
and he did the sake thing and it had
nothing to do with age it was just about
what me and nikki do so yeah no that
one's korea
did i not say japan
[Laughter]
thank you i feel like we need a little
jingle to your like
white-spleening corner i would love that
yeah that's like can we just use that
yeah
steve's corner yeah
steve's corner
this is green book and i'm in the
driver's seat
okay well i'll tell you how to get there
over my head because i didn't see the
movie oh
is that the movie i didn't see either
they told me
it's okay but anyway so parents
if your kids are doing distance learning
don't walk behind
and then [ __ ] be in your underwear i
mean come on people
because you're definitely watching jk
news don't do this i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding
and maybe like turn the computers around
so that you have a white wall behind you
all the time yeah that's just safer
always have that or put a gr put that
green screen effect behind your kids so
it's a little bled out you know
but it has like the galaxy or something
so just to protect yourself
instead of naked you walking through a
living room it's taking you flying
through space
a little more exciting they get a little
different
this is where i am right now really high
yeah
yeah i did have a friend who actually
had to like rearrange his office because
he had it faced out into his living room
before because he works from home
but like his partner just kept appearing
in the background doing whatever so now
he has to turn his desk around so now he
just has a white wall yeah
good call good call so good advice out
there
that's true put a c-stand behind your
kid or something like
the house right thank you
i don't know i've been seeing um some
like
videos of kids pulling pranks on their
teachers and i just got to feel so
bad for the blood like so um there's
this like one kid that was like
orchestrating the whole entire class to
um
turn off their cameras and then like
change their name to reconnecting
and so like right and this is like right
that's good
and this is like right before um a quiz
that they were gonna take because the
teacher was like all right
uh get ready for your quiz and then like
as like as she said that like
everybody just blacked out except for
like one kid
and then nerd was it a prank on that one
kid no no no no no
that kid was the one that was
orchestrating it and so then like the
teacher was like well what happened like
where's everyone and then so she goes
and grabs her husband right
and then the kid was like everybody come
back come back right so all the kids
come back and the husband comes and he's
like what are you talking about
everybody's like here and like
he's like he doesn't even have a [ __ ]
shirt on and then he's like looking at
like
inside the camera he was like what are
we doing right and then she was like i
swear they were just like
like they they were all gone and then i
just feel so bad because like all the
kids were like kind of like giggling and
whatnot and i was like
what the [ __ ] that's so [ __ ] up she's
just trying really hard to be a teacher
no right now the teachers are they have
it like super rough
did you see that one viral tick tock
with the kindergarten teacher
where she was like recording herself and
she was
putting in like so much like animation
and energy like
what do we do with blah blah blah and
like she was just like this like
huge like reaction her voice like so
much energy
and then people were like that's so fake
she turned it on for the tick tock and
then she was like
no man we have to grab their attention
when they're like five years old
so that's why i was wondering like five
hours of kindergarten zoom
like five hours of acting like [ __ ]
with that dude from blue's clue
hey guys that's what my sister says she
says it's
it's obviously exhausting for the kid
and for the teachers
sucks i hope i mean i don't know this
whole thing is just crazy the fact that
we're even in the situation but
i do i have seen online where teachers
are like especially
teachers that aren't like super tech
savvy like older teachers and they're
just
they've been like studying the whole
summer like trying to figure it out and
like
just like putting in so much energy and
effort yeah i'm like oh man that sucks
i'm friends with some of my like high
school teachers like on facebook and
stuff and i'm seeing like they're like
they're trying to like structure like
lesson plans and stuff like that for
they're like students and i'm just like
damn this is crazy
in addition to like also troubleshooting
like i mean even
i'm having trouble with zoom sometimes
just to get into like a work meeting
that i don't need to like teach and i
just need to be
present much less like teach stuff so
that's funny imagine being a teacher you
have to keep the kids
engaged you have to say interesting
things for them and then you also have
the parents over the shoulder
gauging your lesson plan and what you're
saying like [ __ ] sakes that's hard
not just that but then parents like this
where they're [ __ ] smoking weed
when the kids like trying to pay
attention and be there and like yeah
like well we know why this kid can't pay
attention anymore yeah
i know that there was this i think it
was a college class and there's
professor that was just like talking
and i think all the other kids kind of
knew what was going on but like there's
this one kid
that was just in his like at his desk
and i guess you can see in the back that
there's these two people with like ski
mask on that went over and like
literally kidnapped him
and like took him out of the room so it
was just basically like doing like this
and then they were just like going out
into the back and they're just like
taking out through the door and you did
that really well
and then the professor was just like in
the middle of his lecture and he was
like
did did so-and-so just get kidnapped
should we
should we call the cops or anything and
then like you can see his other
classmates were just like kind of like
giggling he was like
i guess he's fine or like something
along that lines like that
no i'm teaching my lesson i'll be like
all right time to call the cops
timmy's missing that's true yeah i
wouldn't [ __ ] around
yeah you wanna play a prank on me you're
gonna
[ __ ] reap what yourself that's right
i like sending the snipers please there
teachers have connections and then you
see like
from their screens
oh
[Music]
[Music]